- What's up y'all,
I'm here with Kate
Flannery and Joel McHale!
Give it up for 'em, y'all.
(crowd cheering)
(audience member whistling)
In honor of St. Patrick's
Day in all its green glory,
it's time for a game called
Things That Are Green.
Kate--
(Irish jig music)
♪ Things that are green ♪
- Nice job, band.
- I didn't actually know
that was going, but nicely done.
- That interruption was
from the band.
- Kate--
(Kate and Kelly laughing)
The band is awesome.
Kate has graciously
agreed to host the game
while I destroy Joel.
(Joel mock laughs)
So tell us the rules, Kate.
- Okay, the rules.
I'm gonna ask you questions
about green things.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- If you hit the buzzer first--
- Yes. (giggles)
- You get the question
right, you get a point.
- Yes.
- Don't hit me, hit the buzzer.
(Kelly giggles)
- Okay.
- If you're wrong, the
other person can steal.
We also have refreshing,
healthy detox green drinks
to replenish you after your day of booze.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Kelly is playing for the lasses
in our house seats.
(audience claps)
Joel is playing for the lads.
(audience member whoops)
The winner gets a cool green prize.
- Yes.
- You ready?
- [Kelly] Yes.
- [Joel] All right,
this is exciting.
- Okay, question number one.
- [Kelly] Okay!
(gentle quiz music)
- What's the lucky meadow weed
that also is a symbol
for St. Patrick's Day?
(Joel grunts)
- Four leaf clover!
(bell dings)
- [Joel] Wrong!
(audience cheers)
- You're gonna have to
come with it, I'm just saying.
- No, it's a dandelion.
- She's bringing it.
- It's a dandelion (laughs).
(audience member chuckles)
- All right, question two.
(gentle quiz music)
Who were the heroes in a half--
Who were the heroes in a half shell?
- I didn't even--
- Ninja turtles!
(bell dings)
You said heroes in a half shell.
(audience claps)
I was a ninja turtle fan.
Were you a ninja turtle--
- I was not ready.
- [Kelly] Sorry.
- You were in a band,
a ninja turtle band?
- I took a breath.
(Kelly laughs)
Wait, wait, wait.
(Kelly laughing loudly)
You were in a band
that dressed up as ninja turtles?
- No, I was a Ninja turtle fan.
- Oh, okay.
That's different.
- But now I want to start a band.
Will y'all be in it?
- Sure. I'm gonna be Raphael.
- I'll be in it.
I'll be Michelangelo.
- Yeah.
- Woo-hoo!
- I wanna be, Michel--
Fine, Donatello.
- I'll be Keith Haring.
(everybody laughing)
- I can see that.
(gentle quiz music)
- What green vegetable
will make your pee smell funny?
- Oh, I got that one.
(Kelly giggles)
Asparagi.
(bell dings)
- Asparagi!
- Oh, thank you.
(audience claps)
- Number four.
(gentle quiz music)
Who had a pig
for a girlfriend and sang,
It's Not Easy Being Green?
- [Kelly] Oh, oh!
Dang.
- Kermit the Frog, everybody.
(bell dings)
- Nice.
- Oh, this one's really good.
- We are tied, it's nice.
- This one's really good.
- We're tied.
It's all tied up here on
the Kelly Clarkson show.
- [Joel] Hold on a second,
I just wanna take a sip.
- Okay.
- All right, refresh yourself.
- [Kelly] Okay.
(laughs loudly) I'll get around
it, don't you even worry.
- Wait, okay.
- Okay.
It's the producers who
got more nervous than...
(Kate laughs)
Than when I brought a lamb on stage.
(Kate and Kelly laughing)
- I'm so ready.
(gentle quiz music)
- Okay, question number five.
Who was the most adorable
character in The Mandalorian?
(Joel grunts)
- Oh!
- The Child.
- [Kelly] No!
(wrong answer buzzer)
- In The Mandalorian,
that's the Baby Yoda.
- [Kelly] No, Baby Yoda!
- Yeah, that's called The Child.
- No, you said The Child!
- It's called The Child.
- It's Baby Yoda!
- Baby Yoda's called The Child!
- Baby Yoda!
- Can we check it?
(audience laughs)
- [Crew Member] It's called The Child.
- [Kelly] Oh, I thought it was Baby Yoda.
(audience laughs)
Damn it, damn it, damn it!
(bell dings)
- Mm!
- [Kate] All right, question number six.
- Yes.
- Mm-hmm.
(gentle quiz music)
- Who's an ogre
who lived in a swamp and
had a best friend named--
- Shrek!
(bell dings)
- All right!
- Dang it.
- That's right.
That's right, Baby Yoda.
- Okay, we are tied.
Ladies and gentlemen, we are tied.
- (groans) I was gonna say Howie Mandel.
- (laughs) What?
(audience chuckles)
- Darn it!
(gentle quiz music)
- Question seven.
Name a yellow fruit that you often buy
from the grocery store when it's green.
- I got that.
- I don't know.
- Who got that?
- No.
- Kelly.
- What, no, because
you're the producer here!
(Kelly giggles)
(audience laughs)
The answer's Howie Mandel.
(Kelly laughs)
(wrong answer buzzer)
- What is the answer?
If you know it, I'll give it to you.
- [Joel] Are you serious?
- Yeah.
- A banana.
- Okay.
(bell dings)
- [Joel] Oh, okay.
(gentle quiz music)
- Question eight.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Who had a house dropped on her?
- Green, the Wicked Witch of the West!
(Joel groans)
(bell dings)
Whoo!
Boom!
- The tie breaker!
- [Kelly] Tie breaker.
- Get serious!
Come on, Joel.
- Hold on.
Let me get my ringer.
- Come on,
put your flask down.
For once in your life.
- Okay.
- [Kate] 'Kay.
♪ For once in my life ♪
(gentle quiz music)
- The last one
is worth five points because
it's in limerick form.
- Oh, geez.
- Okay, yes.
- Okay, his power was actually rad.
He fought all the guys who were bad.
By turning real green
and getting real mean
whenever he got really mad.
- Hulk!
(bell dings)
I just watched it!
(audience cheers)
I just watched End Game!
Whoo!
- There's like twelve of them!
Which one?
- I said End Game!
- Kelly, Kelly, Kelly!
We got a winner, ladies and gentlemen!
(uplifting orchestral music)
- It's so sad
that you're not gonna be on
Blake Shelton's Wall of
Champions because you're not one.
(giggles)
(audience laughs)
- You know what, that's fine.
I'm going on Donahue.
(Kelly cackles)
That's fine.
- Let me--
- I've got another booking.
- (laughs) That means all the
lasses in our house seats win.
(audience claps)
But hell,
it's not easy being green, everybody.
That's our joke for today.
So let's say everyone's a winner.
(imitates air horn)
- This is good, right?
(Joel laughs)
- The Nama Cold Press Juicer is one of the
strongest juicers on the market.
With up to 60% more juice,
The Nama is engineered
to provide more nutrients
and better flavor.
It has multiple functions,
so you can make almond milk, which I love.
Oat milk, and even sorbets,
or even green drinks like these.
This is my personal favorite, whatever.
Plus it's kid safe and super easy to clean
which is what every mom wants to hear.
You're all going to get
a chance to start juicing
because everyone in our house seats
is getting a Nama Juicer!
(imitates air horn)
(audience cheers)
(Joel laughs)